You and the toilet people immediately just because in the ground. That's very difficult to get people.
Once i start doing that to something which is more appropriate. And says i. Drug costs.
And i use holes in the ground for toilets and. Carry water up from the creek in buckets.
And that once people achieve that. Bottom level of servicing. Then i just sort of don't see the need to progress again.
So that's exactly what happens a cycle of poverty.
The lack of servicing means that all people's time and if it is used up. Keeping inefficient. Services going.
Rather than. Possibly. Collectivizing. And making more efficiency and it can be actively destructive.
The lack of organization of services for example is one part in the property where there are six water pipes.
All tied together and big bundle. All running to different places. Because no one trusts. To shia pop with anyone else.
With good reason historically. Because the quickest and easiest way of getting.
Getting back at united for any reason is to cut their water off.
And that causes and they jerk reaction and somebody said that would a cut off. Which is fall and. So. Yes.
I decided no why they were going to do any. Efficient implementation of soft. So the same technology. Vaught.
Communities. The didn't seem to be the degree of trust or resolve or capital.
And as well as that wasn't the quality of the gear they all had to build itself and it was like backyard
and people never trusted it. Or else you had to pay for commercial stuff which is fast we have a priced.
So we decided that the real bottleneck in the implementation of soft earth friendly technology was the commercial
sector. So we decided well. If you can't beat them join them. And we set up a company. To resell at reasonable prices.
And also to manufacture. Or are quite cold technological missing links.
Key things which you need to make a system up right and which you can't buy. And also to get. Purchasing power.
Because it's a very strange world out there in the market. We think that a free market.
And anyone's money is as good as anyone else. But it doesn't work like that. Refusal to. Deal as almost.
The rule not the exception when you come to to buying technological things. And with the top will.
And respectable incorporation of running up our company we found that we had a lot more credibility and buying power.
We could suddenly buy a lot cheaper. And we could get. Get people to sell us things and give us information that.
As individual uprightness was impossible. Because us as becky. He invented.
You've got absolutely no status in this community. Once you've got a business card.
People treat you like you're on the same planet and. That was the main reason that we did it.
And it worked amazingly well. It's like the two societies. An invisible one within the big one.
An invisible one within the big one. It's the people with. Business clout.
With money with respectability who are financially operating. As against the drop out. Inverted commas.
People who are considered as nobodies because they haven't got enough money or political power. Which i guess.
The verse you invented. Bicycles with retitling retiling kicked it all off the been a few people running.
Market stalls. Someone from the co-op and and. Peter from websters creek and. He wasn't actually living there then.
But the people staying during stalls selling things like efficient light bulbs torches. Bits of appropriate technology.
At that the markets. Because the china market was an amazing. Focus of entrepreneurship. And. Appropriate technology.
Was one of the things that went along with that market format. And that's what started the idea of buying and selling.
As a business. And peter had been doing that and i've been doing that. And. Caroline he registered to business.
Sun source. Which is doing the same thing she was buying and selling solar panels. And this buying and selling.
As a way of generating money and getting contacts. Had an obvious. Escalation which was to set up a company.
And that's what happened to you and us. Yeah. Second year i was here i think actually built. First water which worked.
And didn't work very well because it was to keep wearing out drop belts.
That actually produced a useful amount of electricity that it. Actually sat in the creek. And used to get wet.
The drive belt used to slip. And the thing used to wear out.
And also had big political problems with it because there was a an anti technology.
Feeling he had a lot ot mentality and also. I tried to get through the correct processes of getting.
Co-operative endorsement. Of these energy projects.
But all the while i actually got that endorsement for most of the things i did. I actually rise to flag.
And attracted attention from a lot about minorities actually stoned broke interfered with and destroyed.
A lot of the early projects which i put together. And i sort of interference with the spirits of the creek. So.
I'd lot of trouble for the first few years. Eventually i learned my lesson.
And stopped going through the clear correct political process is because they.
Got in the wind they drew thought this is a growing use of got this mindset. When something becomes. Media worthy.
Then it's. Protest worthy and. Whether it's in the newspaper in issue. Or whether it's in the local. Cooperative.
Trouble meetings in issue. It still draws far. And you get a protest movement mobilizing for it and psych and.
Most of the people involved in these things have got minimal understanding.
They tend to be very stupid reactive people. And so i was up against the the most silly extreme group of.
Greenies do it as. As a wife self empowerment. And basically just. Against everything on principle.
And then they turn around and act as total hypocrites from the goodies some of the mainstream.
Technology for their income for. Any white.
How i bitch about the extreme greenies in the early days of this cooperative it was.
It was very rational and very emotional. And my first big technology success. I actually did. Without telling anyone.
With my own money. And my own initiative and bought a great pulse still cable strung it up the cliff.
And put an electric motor on the top and. Created the first. Petrol powered transport system in the whole place.
Which is still working to this diet. Which i think is eighteen years later. I think that's an amazing achievement. And.
It means that i can live. Along with my neighboring four houses without any right access.
We just have a steel cable coming up a two hundred foot cliff.
Is being a very appropriate pace of technology that still lived till you do well just the systems.
Because that's audiology that we didn't want to connect in one more. And it was full size.
Legalities we didn't want to attract. Yet another government authority. To us and.
We wanted to prove that alternatives were possible. So. I built two more water will be for one of actually worked and.
It actually ran for five years before it got. Devastated an enormous flood.
The will itself didn't get broken but the dam across the creek did.
So those limited success with water powered machines at that stage. A little bit lighter i put up a. Recycled windmill.
And that's still working. So there was a bit of sporadic want to off. Successes with energy projects.
But i could see that my life was going to end before many more one else were completed. So i thought that.
Getting commercial. And getting big. And getting messed production was the only way to have any real major impact.
So it would have been a great life and. You know. Yes what's the same thing. Yeah.
So we basically just did in a nor similar commercial why what we did already proved it worked.
So strong that we don't know if it's all yours.
So we did some interesting experimentation with different sorts of generators.
And we actually if we did that fundamental research.
That was necessary to to make things work better than the competition. And we still. We started with no money.
And with no preconceptions this result. Got to a different type of design.
Which works better in smaller sauces than anything on the market tells you how. I do magical idea of living it.
Close it tonight. Without interfering with it. Hundred african genesis by adria like the idea of living in forest.
I hated the thing i detested most about the suburban not man.
So i pledged i would build a house somewhere where i did not have to have a loan. So.
I actually picked a place of totally. Standard. Ordinary eucalypt forest. Which had reasonable access.
Want to put this kind of a lot.
I didn't have to fight any territorial wars with anyone else who wanted to the land all the water all the excess of
something like that. So i was a totally ordinary enormous sot in the middle of an australian mountain range.
And i built a house there. The house was defined very much by the thought it had to be fought proof.
Had to be proof against falling timber. It had to be cheap. It had to be. Might now it's free.
And when i didn't have to protect with nasty chemicals or with chancel.
So then you on the fitted the bill perfectly was a dime.
I don't want been interested in dimes because of the structural elegance.
The use for little materials and free high strength and.
One wind which we can use less of the earth's resources just use more efficient structures.
Like my house twice ten tonnes.
That might sound a lot
but your average brick veneer house with a fraction of the strength wise about ten times that amount. So.
And the environmental impact was there. It was measurable. The thing was made of cement and steel.
But you've got a definite environmental impact. It's not pretty. You'll be bad.
If you look at the last cycle impact of that technology. And a small amount of the dough used. So.
It was basically just a demonstration of living. Soft impact housing. No.
Hug no them and let me listen both in that mike why if you don't drool file.
So i went to all the right moves with a cooperative. I even put in a picture of it to the building inspector.
Just the minimum. Application.
I got the message back he didn't believe in diamonds and that was the end of it now for the correspondence
and into until seven years later i suddenly discovered that all have become legal.
But into being an existing structure. So that limits of like are about to fall on my side.
But then we put in small planes and got the thing. Legitimist and us. Actually.
Thanks to pull landa pass not ordinance seventy. But structural engineering testing.
Which of course my house passed easily in fact i became part of the test flight. Most of them top of the.
Ton of white on the weakest place. So that's a lot of fun. It was not feeling that slight amount of.
Bureaucratic acceptability. All those different issues of the dime was too weak.
This would irritate me so much about two hundred seventy it was not about strength. It's not about appropriateness.
It's not even about health. Was about code.
And the fact that you've got the option to either get your structure passed by code or by engineering tests.
I think is the why the world should be. Personal off with disastrous terribly lonely. Not living.
I was living in one of the hamlets in the place.
And we worked pretty much as a group and we got together
and so on i became quite quite mad from sleeping alone for too many years. And there's an enormous shortage of women.
And the ones that would tend to be attracted by people with more services of course. Not to lived on top of the cliff.
That wasn't so much the trouble. It was really as a conflict between. Homestead is and free love hippies.
And we had this both. Ideals. Side by side literally. Where you know.
You get one lot of neighbors to be very morally vindictive about people sleeping around.
And then you'd have next door people who didn't believe in marriage in the least.
And if you try to possessive that was a heavy trip man.
And i believe reality is sort of somewhere in between the two extremes. And i think that's where i was was.
But i had a reputation as a terrible flandrau. Which i wasn't totally deserved.
And i didn't make it as one of the bridges. This was. When you. Now. Yes. It's awful to a lot of reverse sexism.
In this community. I don't know whether i was totally right.
Plus it may be perceived that men were considered just extremely expendable. And trishna very mercenary white.
Simply as house builder. You see. The role of a man in that utopian community was extremely ill defined.
In many of the cases the women. Usurped the natural. Roles of men.
I'm not complaining about that i think it's appropriate that i did. But the women were. Roles are extremely aggressive.
Though totoro. Very much in their own pecking order. They were very interested in the minutes of the games.
Men became very much also around us and their own uses whether they could produce food or. Build houses.
They would have any financial use. Because women could get more much more money from other.
Growing diaper or social security or even prostitution in a few cases. So many. Now use would have us financially.
And once had built the hell so usually disposed of as well. And there's a shortage of women.
Do a bit more menace is always been the case and yes drug and outback and.
A lot of the women were coming from a situation of. Persecution. In fact.
I think cynthia generalize that many women who ended up here. Were coming here to skype. Six just oppression.
Balmain and men came here for audio list dick. Dreams of freedom and. And utopia.
Women tend to come here to escape maine. And i think had a miserable time because back in suburbia. They got basically.
Used financially by being under the thumb of men. Particularly when they had young kids.
That came here to get a wife mean. And suddenly they could have their freedom. But then they found the tyranny.
That they didn't have enough service situations. They missed that they missed their houses.
And particularly when you got young kids. I think you need servicing more than ever you do. In your life.
Suddenly all of the. The middle class values of. Flush toilets and cars and. Security and things like that.
Become very important because you've got little kids. And that. That makes it a necessity.
So many why what i was getting to i guess is that men were saying very much this is mostly rain. Contracts.
And the game was. You build houses and fix cars. And you get to go to bed with me.
And that was the why the social contract worked. And of course.
There were many cardia lost a belief
and so might some believed in equality of the sexes i believed in old a sort of lovely flowers child sort of stuff and.
I was extremely hurt. To be taken as purely as a provider of the building. So i did a bit of. Building houses.
And a bit of fixing people's water pipes and a lot of wiring people's houses and all sort of thing. But it seemed that.
Sex in return for libel. Was it was unsatisfying emotionally. So it was and was not generally do. Much.
And the wasn't masada keep falling in love with women. Was a terrible problem. And of course.
Men are a nuisance particularly if they're in love with you.
So i mean you try to make demands because your happiness is totally dependent upon getting in someone else's bed which
i think the facile situation but that's the situation much most men found themselves. So. Well just like that.
Get fall in love with people. Kept slipping a line. Kept feeling depressed. There's a socket whenever never again.
Was there was a decision. You might consider more. Yes very strongly. It seemed like a bad joke.
When i was after that fifteen years. You did less than that actually but twelve years of this.
Was long enough to try out a lovely. Loft options. And the final option always want to children and.
When i discovered that i store all anyway that was like the last bad joke.
It seemed like a way of disposing of that whole problem area of my life i would do all we got dust up on whole months.
That work unbelievably well. I recommend it for many. Depressive suicidal lovesick miles. It's worked. It's worked.
It's solved that problem totally. Yes. It was a problem. So quite frankly i'd thought that was a problem.
I didn't know them anything. I thought it was their problem to do with and it was not really a problem anyway.
The whole thing was quite quite funny. How did you lose. Oh i get treated as bad.
But then most people are treated as mad who live here anyway so what does that mean.
It did for the worse and the credibility problem.
I felt that i always had communication problems because i was being shouted down by a loud mouth people who repeated
themselves ten times
and got the why that was sort of like a syndrome which had been going ever since the beginning of the co-operative.
I couldn't build. If my made it drop in status but i can't live untouchable compared with being a schoolteacher.
I wasn't particular thora to the school teacher
but all got christmas at least anyone who was coming he was a mediately suspect.
Because also from the straight science community which is considered as a as a demonic religion. And i didn't ever.
Doubt my principles of oracle stright science.
Madea's of truth my belief structure i think is the why i put it now and never been under much threat and never
and still isn't. And for that reason i was considered a little bit spiritually limited. And very suspect.
And certainly not a. Accorded much credibility in the community. So that got a bit worse with agenda china.
Because women tend not to have much credibility on other. Particular it comes to cost. And things like that that.
Men use as a get props. Because we're in. Them and. It's very male dominated. It tends to involve.
My league is very heavily and. It's considered as. Mad and lacking in credibility anyway. Because people.
Almost worship. Minds palak minds water. The utility authority.
Is very close to the image of miles already and in our culture.
And anyone who doesn't believe in those things has got to be a minute. I mean to peddle suffered a lot of this.
He was considered an impractical. People sort of. People actually accept him quite well.
Because he's so obviously eccentric. That. It's not a threat that he disagrees with them.
So in that way he was much more successful at putting his message across than me who was but more of a sort of a.
At the gnawing revolutionist.
All saying this is morally wrong and stupid the why things are done with he wouldn't be nearly second front.
They could see rick sipadan pedals having. Silly ideas like that one should could pedal.
To write pal to run a television set.
People can laugh at it people can treat him as a joke and for that reason he's not as confronting. All those much.
Less tech flossing people didn't want to hear what i had to tell them. So i was had this credibility problem.
As you will see. I've learned about. A few things. I've become very cynical about women's motivation. In love a face.
But then i also don't hold it against them. I think that.
It just means a very different thing to a woman and man to be in love.
And i think the noisy vaadia is that there's no difference between the sexes.
That was around in the sixty's and seventy's it's been proved wrong.
Is an enormous difference between the sexes in lots of things. Well yes i know women are coming from.
And i also know a lot more about what women are coming from too because i've become one in many wise. Most.
Most of all was exclusively. Changed. Sexual part in this will is gender and that is most people died. You know.
You know. In the history of tangible. It was an amazing social experiment. And it's still going on and. I think.
Money is the key thing which. Now. Turns out to be central to the whole issue.
Incredible damage was done to our coalition as a community by. Money. As in drug money.
And in social security money was paid. In the why which could be most destructive. To community spirit.
A little bit vicious about the department of social insecurity on that one. Why in which they headed up the money.
Was almost obviously designed to destroy any community based movement. It was given to individuals.
On behalf of their kids. It was given to women were paid to leave maine. As one of the effect of the white structure.
You were paid to scam. You only paid if you lost. And you got. Continually. Kept in a state of paranoia.
Random an unreasonable cut offs.
It was a lack of any long range contracting about the payment of social security so that people didn't use it
efficiently. And couldn't use it efficiently.
And it maintained a sort of a live from die to die my life style which is absolute death. In any plain community.
Because nearly everything which is productive has got to be kept going over a long period.
So money was very destructive. The effect of the drug itself was destructive. Lots of people became alcoholics and.
Heavy dope smokers. And i think that through lots of. Psychiatric of the times that.
Heavy use of marijuana which is not being fully admitted. I think at the very least. It encourages different psychosis.
Paranoia forgetfulness and laziness are obvious.
But i think this deeper things than that to like this is the talk of schizophrenia that people get
and i've been smoking a long time. Children. Is the other enormous factor. You can't underestimate how much.
Children here. Partly because of living in such a close situation an extended family. Had enormous power.
Outside society especially constructed to protect people from children put in schools.
That they're bombarded with media. And there are the rules. And authorities about how they meant to be treated.
He is there are no rules and. Justice in the politics. The people the latticed voices tend to get the most site.
Children because i like a lot of noise. Tend to totally dominate was the tao and the dog.
Many family groups were totally dominated by the needs of the children and.
I think to the children side destruction insane. Civil cases. So the children. Get brought up. Totally spoilt.
Self indulged.
By the time that they take in the smoking dope all the time the twelve that died peddling heroin on the street.
And that's why a lot of our children have gone. It's just too easy. Now if this is on constructive behavior.
Would you say you know i have no idea. I consider myself a genuine small liberal but also a moralist.
In that i think you haven't got a right to take what you can get. You've got a.
An obligation to a community at least as much as yourself and lots of people that are totally selfish.
And you know this is going to be a balance between the rights of the individual in the community. It's.
It's as a very obvious statement it's also a fundamental. What about the challenges. You know. When you sit in this.
Now. You know. You know. Things. Yes. Gradually the conventional services.
Are becoming more expensive than not being subsidized as much by government.
And then some much in the way of compulsory can. Consumption.
Because so much of western culture us is compulsory can consumption.
People don't even know how much that consuming half the time. Like starting to at least measure.
Water rights in lismore. And you pay more if you use more water.
I mean that radical ideas on me just now appeared in lismore. There's a funny attitude towards. Services rights.
That you have for being a. What anglo-saxon process.
Was considered the right to consume the world's resources on the very modest one. So that feeling's coming in.
Also appropriate technology is getting a lot cheaper.
And thanks to people are growing up our company is getting more valuable service to backed.
All of those things that consumers want. Solar panels for example of consistently been getting better and cheaper.
So that now you can actually run a remote house on solar panels. If you're careful.
I think the biggest success this particular property has had with energy and. Impact is that.
It's not so much to have done anything different.